[Music]
I'm Tyler I'm a disciple of more time
this is proper hand wrapping technique
from white I okay so what we're gonna do
here is I'm gonna give you guys a quick
little intro on how to wrap the hand
everyone has their own different way of
doing it I'm gonna give you the basic of
my version I like to use the Mexican
wraps in general that have a little more
of the spandex material involved in this
so I take the little loop I'm gonna put
around my thumb I'm gonna give it two
revolutions or two wraps around my wrist
and I do that right directly around the
main part of your wrist after the second
revolution what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to come through and I like to come
through between one of my middle fingers
what we do this is to kind of give
yourself a nice snug fit in between your
knuckles I'm gonna come back around the
middle and go back down the middle of my
finger now basically every time I do is
I'm putting a a line and a wrap in
between each one of my fingers I'm gonna
pull back down I'm gonna go to the
middle part of my other finger here okay
then I go back across top of my hand and
from here you can kind of go and do it
any way that you want as long as you do
it properly enough to where you cover
and have all the surface area of your
hand pretty much wrapped up now what I
like to do is I like to what we call
make a pillow across the knuckles okay
that gives me just a little more cushion
across the surface part of my knuckles
that will make it a little easier on
your hands when you really start
punching so what I do is I come across
here and now I'll take a little fold
back and forth so I take a little pillow
here fold that down
one more little little pillow I'm going
to pull this wrap back here threw it
across gonna come down here a little bit
I hold it with my pinky
pull it tight come back around come back
around back across the wrist again the
back around the wrist and now I'm coming
around I'm going to actually go up and
around and support my thumb joint here a
little bit again around the front of the
knuckles come all the way back here
through the back and then back across
the wrist again and try to get as much
area around that wrist as I can
where you have a nice solid secure rap
and then when you're done basically what
you've done is you've kind of cross
wrapped your hand to a point where now I
have a nice little surface area in front
of your knuckles the side of my thumb is
also protected give it a little support
so that when you're throwing your
punches or your boxing you don't have to
worry about that thump kind of pulling
out as much in general and then to make
sure that I have a very good amount of
revolutions and wraps around my wrist so
that when you're throwing punches in
different direction that you have a
little support that your wrist is not
going to get pushed back in different
directions in general and by doing that
you'll have a nice solid surface area
and it should be the best way to keep
your hands a safe and protect as
possible make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes
[Music]